c'était 100 saas c'est ton frère alan
qu'est ce que tu fais là
eh bien nous devions nous voir pour
préparer notre week-end la salle
omnisports tiens tiens stephen
[Musique]
plaisir de vous voir dans ce podcast ça
fait longtemps d'ailleurs j'ai croisé
vos fils allan et steven toujours en
train de se chamailler ces deux là ils
sont en tout cas en très bonne santé ce
qui n'est malheureusement pas votre cas
m
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais là
rien rien on discute
ah oui et vous discutez de quoi des
concerts des concerts c'est vrai qu'il
doit y avoir un tas de trucs marrants à
dire sur les concerts et qu'est ce que
vous disiez à ce sujet qu'est ce qui m'a
pris de dire ça si je ne trouve rien à
dire sur les concerts il va comprendre
que nous n'étions pas du tout en train
de discuter
[Musique]
les nouvelles ne sont pas bonnes
monsieur podcast en tant que proches
incontesté de cette famille je me dois
de vous dire la vérité
oui alors qu'est ce que vous dites
[Musique]
alors vous disiez quoi que je me disais
que ce qui est marrant c'est qu'il n'y a
que dans les salles de concerts qu'on
reste une heure et demie debout à
écouter de la musique
oui tu t'imagines l'écouté du michael
dans ton salon debout comme ça prendra
une heure et demie c'est ça que je
disais
[Musique]
j'ai déjà fait refaire ma cuisine il y a
6 mois je n'ai pas le budget et encore
moins le temps pour ça excusez moi comme
je vous le disais l'heure est grave
concernant vos examens
[Musique]
ah oui ça n'aurait pas de sens d'écouté
de la musique comme ça pendant une heure
et demie debout dans ce monde est
d'accord
j'étais en train de m'imaginer le truc
en fait c'est pour ça que je parlais
plus à ok c'était comme ça dans ton
salon comme ça pendant une heure et
demie t'imagines le gars il vous avez dû
quoi d'autre merde
[Musique]
le propriétaire de la voiture
immatriculée 0,92 est là j ai prié de
déplacer son véhicule
merci c'est à vous où en est elle à oui
je vais vous dire les choses le plus
simplement du monde
vous allez qui cela peut-il bien être je
vois pertinemment votre point train de
taper sur la table dr miles
vous aimez trop faire des suspenses vous
les médecins à temps pour à chaque fois
c'est moi c'est bon stop ça suffit
j'ai le droit de savoir ce que j'ai
monsieur podcast j'ai le regret de vous
annoncer que vous allez tomber dans le
coma eh bien vous savez quoi dr miles
cette nouvelle me ravit quoi
[Musique]
philou je reconnais bien là monsieur
podcast d'agde à part comment on fait
pour le commun du coup parce qu'il se
trouve que j'ai un planning chargé
réjouissez vous monsieur podcast je vous
ai prévenu suffisamment à l'avancé pour
que vous puissiez vous organisé par
exemple décider lequel de vos deux fils
va reprendre l'entreprise familiale de
fils suis-je bête je veux dire trois
fils
mes trois fils
[Musique]
bah alors vous n'avez dit que ça je sais
prends je lui disais notamment que les
premières parties des concerts c'est
comme les préliminaires pour les garçons
c'est pas pour ça qu'on a payé le ticket
mais on est obligé de se les coltiner si
on veut pouvoir voir bien jouer steven
t'es le meilleur
et dieu seul qui a maquillé ateurs les
premières parties l'estac à rennes
attend stephen que tu répéter ce que tu
viens de dire merde quelconque tu ne
respectes donc rien steeple ce n'est pas
du tout ce que tu crois alan la blague
que tu viens de faire sur les
préliminaires
c'est une blague dans friends comment
oses-tu faire une blague de fresnes sans
citer la source
ces chaleurs qui fait cette blague dans
l'intro du deuxième épisode de la saison
1 et tu le sais très bien ne fait pas
l'innocent je ne le savais pas aussi à
cheval sur le vol de blague je ne savais
pas qu'il connaissait aussi bien friends
[Musique]
oui vos trois fils steven alan et
brendon votre fils caché mes trois fils
dieu je vais toujours que j'ai un fils
caché à ça c'est comme ça c'est con hein
faut le noter il ya une appli ils
oublient ou on peut noter à tous les
fils caché qu'on a parce que moi j'avais
mis un post it un sur le frigo et saha
posted c'est qu'on est une appli un
rappel à une beauty fun ou titre i'm not
il ça marche toujours très fin on l'a
toujours sur soi
bon bon bon relais voile rancune un
bonbon comar d écouter tous remercient
qui de alan ou de steven ou de brandon
reprendre à l'entreprise familiale
vous le serez prochainement dans les
frères podcast peut-être pas dans
l'épisode suivant mais accrochez-vous
on va pas tarder à le savoir moi j'ai
donné pour sûr de trucs en général
[Musique]